we're on problem 46. in the figure below
line segment a b is parallel
to c
see i think there's a typo here i've got
to believe this is going to be c d
that's got to be a typo all right so a b
i'm assuming is parallel to cd that's
probably what they wanted to have
because you can't be parallel to a
vertex all right they say what is the
value of x
so the way to think about it is let's
you know if these two are parallel lines
then this segment up here is a
transversal right if we just extend
the two lines like this let me see if i
can do it well
so if i extended that line like that
and if i extended this line like that
then segment a d is just a transversal
let me see if i can do that one right
so if i just extended it like that you
see it's a transversal i can go the
other direction as well
i think you get the idea
so if that is a transversal what do you
know about transversal we know we know
that
let's see
x plus this angle right here
this i'll draw it small is congruent to
this angle over here so the measure of
this angle is also x plus 40
right
because they're corresponding angles and
you could see that by inspection and if
you moved around the transversal it
would make sense that that's the case so
this is x plus 40 and this is x minus 40
and they're clearly supplements of each
other they're supplementary angles then
the sum of these two angles have to be
equal to 180. so let's figure it out so
x minus 40
plus x plus 40
is equal to 180 because they're
supplementary let's see the 40s cancel
out so you just minus 40 plus 40 adds up
to zero so we're left with 2x
is equal to 180
x is equal to 90. so it's d
d
47 the measures of the interior angles
of a pentagon
are okay they give us 2x 6x 4x minus 6
2x 16 and 6x plus 2.
what is the measure in degrees of the
largest angle okay so first of all we
have to remember what is the sum of the
interior angles of a pentagon and that's
where i always i just draw an arbitrary
pentagon let me see if i can do that
let me see actually there's a polygon
tool here so let me see how does it work
let's see one
so i'm just trying to draw a pentagon
three
four 5
i don't know if that's any different
than the line tool but regardless so how
many triangles can i draw a pentagon
that tells me what my total interior
angles are and there is a formula for
that but i like relying on your
reasoning more than the formula because
you might forget the formula or even
worse you might remember it but not have
the confidence to use it or you might
remember it wrong 10 years in the future
so the best thing to do is if you have a
polygon just count the triangles in it
straightforward enough it's almost
easier than using the formula so
pentagon has three triangles in it so
the sum of its interior angles are going
to be three
are going to be
so the sum of all of the angles are
going to be three times 180 right
because it has three triangles in it and
each triangle has 180 degrees i know you
can't see what i just wrote right
so the sum of all of these angles are
going to be the sum of all of the angles
in all in all three triangles so 3 times
180 is equal to 540 degrees
so that's the sum of
all of these interior angles now they
say that each of them are you know 2x 6x
etc so the sum of all of these terms
have to be equal to 540. so we could
write i'm going to write them vertically
makes them easier to add so if we write
they're x
six x
four x minus six
two x
minus sixteen
and six x plus two
six x plus two this is going to be the
largest right
that sum is going to equal 540 so let's
add this up minus 6 minus 16 that's
minus 22
plus 2
is minus 20
right that's right yeah because we have
my yeah
minus 48 minus 20 and then i have 2 x
plus 6x that is 8x plus 4 is 12 12 plus
2 is 14
14 plus
6 is 20. so we have 20x
minus 20 is equal to 540 degrees
i know i'm
you can't see that 500 let me write it
again 20x
minus 20 is equal to
540.
let's divide both sides of this equation
by 20.
so you get x
minus 1 is equal to let's see 54 divided
by
see it would be 54 divided by 2 which is
equal to 27
so then x is equal to add 1 to both
sides x is equal to 28 and they want to
know what is the measuring degrees of
the largest angle that's going to be
this one right that's the largest one
it's 6 times x plus 2. so
6 times 28 what's 28
times 6.
it's 48
2 times 6 is 12 plus 4 is 168
so it's 168
plus 2 so plus 2
it's 170 degrees
choice c
problem 48
what is the measure of angle
one the measure of angle one so this
we're going into the angle game and
these are fun because they're kind of
these deductive reasoning problems where
you just use a couple of simple rules
and you just fill it the whole thing so
let's think about it
this is 36 degrees they tell us that
this whole angle right here is a right
angle so what this angle right here is
going to be the complement to 36 degrees
right 36 plus this angle have to be
equal to 90. so what's this one this one
is 90
minus 36 which is what 54 right
that's going to be 54 degrees 90 minus
30 is 60 right this 54.
and now this angle
right here that's going to be the
supplement of 88 so this is going to be
i'll do it in a different color
minus 88
that is equal to
92 degrees
now this angle 1 plus the 54 plus the 92
is equal to 180 so we know that
you know measure let's say angle one
plus 54
plus 92 is equal to 180
so angle one let's see 54 plus 92 is 96.
this is 146 is that right 146 i think
that is equal to 180
subtract 146 from both sides the measure
of angle 1 is equal to
let's see
80 minus 40 80 minus 40 is 40 so 80
minus 46 is equal to 34 degrees so the
answer is a
problem 49
what is the measure of angle w
z x so they want to know what this angle
right here is so let's let's do the
angle game some more so let's see we can
immediately figure out what this angle
is
because it is the supplement of 132
degrees so this is going to be 180
minus 132 and that's what 80 minus 32 80
minus 30 is 50 minus 2 is so this is 48
degrees
so this one's 48
this angle plus this angle is going to
be equal to this angle
right so this angle or this angle plus
this angle plus this angle is equal to
180 i don't know what i just said i
think i said something wrong so the sum
of the so these let's say write that
down so this angle is going to be equal
to 180
minus 52 minus 48 because the sum of the
angles add up to 180
and so that is equal to
minus let's see
let's see that's minus 100
right
which equals 80 degrees so this angle
right here
is equal to 80 degrees
and the angle they want us to figure out
is the opposite of this angle or in in
the us i guess they say vertical angles
so this is and so opposite or vertical
angles are equal or they're congruent so
this is going to be 80 degrees as well
and that is choice a
problem 50
what is the measure of an exterior angle
of a regular hexagon
so a regular hexagon tells us that all
the sides are the same it's equilateral
and all of the angles are the same
equiangular
so if we just knew how many what's the
total degree measure of the interior
angles we could just divide that by six
and then
that would give us what the each of the
interior angles are and then we could
use that information to figure out the
exterior angle so let's just do it so
once again
i like to just draw a hexagon
let's just draw a hexagon and count the
triangles in it
two sides three sides four sides five
sides
and six sides
and how many triangles do i have here
see i could draw one length one
two
three so i have
one two three four triangles so the
interior the measure the sum of the
interior angles of this hexagon of any
hexagon whether it's regular or not are
going to be 4 times
and that's equal to what
that's equal to 720
180 times 2 is 360 right that's equal to
720 degrees
and there's a regular hexagon so all the
interior angles are going to be the same
so and there are six of them so each of
them
are going to be 720 divided by six
720 goes into well 6 goes into
72 12 times
right
so each of the angles of this regular
hexagon are going to each of the
interior angles are going to be 120
degrees i know i didn't draw it that
regular but we can assume that all of
these are each
120 degrees
fair enough now if all of those are each
120 degrees what is the measure of an
exterior angle well we could just extend
one of these sides out a little bit
and we could say okay if this is 120
degrees what is its supplement
well these have to add up to 180 so 180
minus 120 is 60 degrees right i could do
it on any side i could
extend that line out there and say oh
that's 60 degrees so any of the exterior
angles are 60 degrees
b
all right let's see do you have time for
one more i'll wait for the next one in
the next video see you soon